auch kroatien ist ein beliebtes
reiseziel für viele menschen aus
deutschland auch sehr regelmäßig und wir
sind in kroatien haben uns umgeschaut
noch ist die einreise nach kroatien für
touristische zwecke nicht möglich doch
innerhalb des landes werden die korona
maßnahmen immer weiter gelockert
so haben zum beispiel restaurants schon
wieder geöffnet und auch die paar stufen
mittlerweile wenn auch in begrenzter
anzahl gäste empfangen die menschen hier
in rubin an der westküste des landes
nutzen die neuen freiheiten und freuen
sich tatsächlich darüber mal keine
touristen um sich zu haben
wir brauchen die touristen sagt
barkeeperin sandra sie bringen das geht
aber mal ein sommer ohne das wäre nicht
schlecht
die kroatische regierung sieht das ein
bisschen anders
der tourismus gehört zur wichtigsten
branche des landes war 2009 10 für 17
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes
verantwortlich deshalb setzt die politik
auch alles daran dass im sommer wieder
urlauber einreisen können
wir werden sehen man die leute kommen
sagt sandra nach der pandemie im august
vielleicht auf jeden fall später als
sonst
kroatien selbst kam in der korona krise
vergleichsweise glimpflich davon
das land verzeichnete etwas mehr als
2000 infektionswelle 90 menschen sind
bisher an den folgen gestorben
klingt alles sehr entspannt da in
kroatien mattes katnik ist für uns vor
ort machte
wenn du dich um hörst unter den
hoteliers restaurantbetreibern und co
wie ist die stimmung
die stimmung ist eigentlich im großen
und ganzen positiv dias kartells machen
jetzt wieder auf und auch an diesem
wochenende haben schon einige
campingplätze und prozent angekündigt
dass wir nachts in erster linie werden
jetzt erstmal nur die kroatischen
touristen kommen nämlich montag in
zeitpunkt und hier wieder im landkreis
und ich habe mit ihr gesprochen der hat
mir sogar gesagt bei vier wochen einer
chance zu 50 prozent ausgebucht
wunderbar also da ist man guten mutes
dass die saison doch noch stattfindet
und welche angebote gibt es denn
vielleicht tatsächlich auch in richtung
deutsche touristen sowie den deutschen
touristen wird wahrscheinlich im juni so
weit sein dass die einreisen können das
gibt es die ersten lockerungen bereits
seit montag sind allerdings nur für
menschenleben einen zweitwohnsitz jahren
die ein boot hier haben die auf business
reise nach kroatien unterwegs sind oder
auch wenig wirtschaftlichen unten
einreisen
und dieser punkt natürlich etwas
interpretationsspielraum
und es soll angeblich so sein dass wenn
man eine hotel bestätigung hat dass man
interesse an allerdings ist das dann so
dass ein ganz beamte auch jeder sagen
kann nein und die kroatische zentrale
für tourismus man ja nach vorn jetzt
einzureißen
es wird wie gesagt wahrscheinlich im
juni möglich sein vor allem auch dann
wenn es in deutschland die ganze gruppe